[موسيقى]
هل تتذكرون ماذا ارتديتم عند ذهابكم الى
العمل الاسبوع الماضي او ماذا تناولتم على
الغداء في مثل هذا اليوم من الشهر الفائت
ما رايكم بان هناك اشخاصا يستطيعون تذكر
هذه التفاصيل بكل سهوله حتى لو كانت قبل
سنوات طويله لكن ذاكرتهم القويه تحولت الى
ماساه تؤرق حياتهم انها متلازمه فرط
الاستذكار النادره تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على
قصه جديده منه عالم غريب
كم يتمنى مريض الزهايمر ان يتذكر ولو لحظه
جميله من حياته وكم يرغب الطالب بان
يسترجع معلوماته خلال الامتحان لكن
المصابين بمتلازمه فرط الاستذكار او
الهايبر يحدث معهم العكس تماما يفقدون
بسببها قدرتهم على نسيان تفاصيل حياتهم
وتجاربهم الشخصيه مهما مرت السنوات
يتذكرون ادق التفاصيل بما فيها لافتات
الشوارع وارقام الهواتف والسيارات
يمكنهم باستمرار تذكروا كل يوم مر من
حياتهم وكل حدث وكل تاريخ وكل ذكرى عشوها
ذاكرتهم اشبه بجهاز تخزين يحفظ جميع
المشاهد بلا استثناء ويعرضها امام اعينهم
كانهم يعيشون المشهد من جديد حتى لو مضت
عليه سنوات وسنوات
لم يسمع احد عن متلازمه فرط الاستذكار قبل
عام 2000 حين ارسلت شابه تدعى جيل برايس
الى عالم الاعصاب جيماكجو تخبره انها
تستطيع ان تتذكر كل يوم من حياتها منذ
كانت في الثانيه عشره من عمرها وطلبت منه
المساعده وبعد دراسات وابحاث مطوله اصبحت
برايس اول شخص على الاطلاق تشخص حالتها
بمتلازمه فرط الاستذكار وهي حاله نادره
جدا لم يشخص بها اكثر من مئه شخص حول
العالم
عندما كان عمري حوالي اسبوع واحد اتذكر
انني كنت ملفوفه ببطانيه قطنيه ذات لون
زهري وكنت دائما اعرف ان امي تحملني لسبب
ما
الى يومنا هذا لا يوجد تفسير طبي واضح
لاسباب الاصابه بمتلازمه فرط الاستذكار
لكن دراسه اجريت عام 2014 طردت ان السبب
بيولوجي وان الاشخاص الذين يعانون منها
لديهم نشاط مفرط في اجزاء معينه من الدماغ
رغم ان فحوص الدماغ لم تكشف عن اختلافات
تشريحيه ضخمه تفسر المتلازمه وهناك اعتقاد
اخر يفترض ان السبب قد يكون وراثيا او
نفسيا
جميعنا يود لو كان يتحلى بذاكره قويه لكن
يبدو ان النسيان نعمه كبيره حرم منها
هؤلاء لتتحول ذاكرتهم القويه الى لعنه
ترافقهم في كل لحظه خصوصا عندما يتعلق
الامر بالذكريات الحزينه والمؤلمه فمع كل
مره تمر امامهم الام الماضي بدقه عاليه
يعيشون مشاعر الالم او الندم وكانها تحدث
لاول مره الامر الذي يزيد من الم المتذكر
ومعاناته ورغم ان المتلازمه لا تحمل اي
اثار جانبيه جسديه او مضاعفات فانها قد
تكون مرهقه عقليا لصاحبها اما من ناحيه
العلاج فلا دواء الشافيا حتى اليوم للتخلص
نهائيا من متلازمه فرط الاستذكار لكن
العلاج النفسي قد يساعد المريض في اداره
ذلك الكم الهائل من الذكريات والتركيز على
استدعاء الجيد منها وتجاهل المؤلم
[موسيقى]